foreign
divorced 50 years ago and recently we
were told that they want to remarry two
months ago they decided to go on a
little getaway together and they told us
just as friends
I love it
what up what up this is John the Dr John
deloney show
show for you about you and honestly by
you
a show where people call they're
struggling with real stuff going on in
their life whether it's their marriage
their Mental Health
challenges with their physical health
parenting whatever you got going on in
your life your dating relationships
whatever my promise is I'll sit with you
and we will figure out what to do next
and unlike most uh internet podcasting
gurus I don't have all the answers I
don't know everything I promise you that
um but my commitment is that I'll find
out
people who do
or I'll find the information and if I
don't know I'll say I don't know but
here's the deal I'm gonna tell you the
truth and I'm gonna sit with you as we
figure out what to do next if you want
to be on this show give me a shoot me an
email John deloney.com ask ask and you
just go on the website fill out the form
and it goes to Jenna and Kelly and they
sort through them and create the show or
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and you can leave a
message and then we'll have you on to be
fantastic all right let's go out down
the street to Knoxville Tennessee and
let's talk to
Mary Mary
what's up Mary
hello John how are you good and you
I'm doing very well thank you
outstanding appreciate you appreciate
you taking my call and seeing what we
can do about this all right let's do it
what's up
okay so I am engaged to a man
um this is both of our second marriages
were
um early 50s uh prior marriages those 20
plus years
um and all that we've been together over
two years uh engaged for about a year of
that
in the beginning of our relationship
um he was very open with me about why
his prior marriage ended and that was
because he had
he was in a very toxic relationship that
had been in order to cope with that was
using escort services for
probably five to ten years or so
um and this was all done very covertly
his his ex knew nothing about it until
one day
she discovered a piece of mail about a
declination of of a credit application
that he was trying to get additional
credit
um in his name a little
he had an apartment with this person
with this escort that he was being very
regularly almost in a relationship type
of situation
[Music]
um and so this was discovered his
divorce ensued and
you know they tried to go through
counseling
um
you know and you know we can only
believe so much about what people tell
us about their past that he did show me
the divorce papers and confirmed that
this is a legitimate story
um and so I was very grateful to get you
know have him come clean
um
you know and I'm certainly not perfect
either with my prior marriage
um not in in that sense of the meaning
but you know in other things where I
recognized where I had failures as well
um so moving forward
um we've have great chemistry is like
zero drama like it's so refreshing to
have zero drama with somebody
um and so
you know in the last we had some
financial difficulties this early spring
he lost his job
um and was you know able to to get by
um I didn't have to cover him or
anything but it was you know he's a very
proud man in terms of wanting to be a
good provider and so that puts some
stress on him
and I felt like something was off and so
I did confront him and I felt like this
is it's more than just the finances
what's going on
and he admitted that
um you know and he showed me his phone
in his email where these escort service
ads started to roll into his inbox again
in April
um I
you know I'm confronted him about it he
was very open with it he's never hidden
his phone for me but just I don't
routinely look at stuff because
it's just not in my nature I'd rather
just trust and deal with whatever
happens I don't want to be
I don't feel like a grown man he's a
babysitter if you know what I mean
absolutely
um so
I'm just really disappointed
um I knew from the beginning that it
would be a risk
I don't I don't believe that he has
actually taken action on that but the
fact that it's rolling in his inbox is
still I do it's a very risky Behavior
yeah I do did not fall back into that
pattern of a coping mechanism well like
Mary these these things
I've got multiple email addresses for
different things
not one time has an escort service
well not one time as an escort service
just rolled into my inbox yeah I know
that's not how that works so and so I
didn't believe the story that it was
just you said oh I have this account
open that I didn't realize was still
open that's bull crap when you logged
into that account and he absolutely knew
it was open of course he did so I I
don't buy that he's not
um
for lack of better words that he's not
using again
right I don't either the the challenge
here is
the reason this is escalated risk if you
will is
um
I and hear me parse this out this isn't
a moral parsing or a character logical
parsing or even me trying to get cute
this is me just talking about safety
um there is
somebody who's married who has a
one-night fling after an office party
with an office co-worker there's that
right
there is somebody who has meet somebody
at work or meet somebody at the park
where their kids play and they develop a
long-term emotional affair
there is long-term sexual affairs with
people when they're not when they're
married all that stuff happens
I've got an escort is a physical
biological risk to me that an escort
using escort services in my opinion is a
whole other layer because you're not
just the illusion when you have a
one-night stand or the illusion that you
you know when you have an affair is you
are just
um just this is just between me and that
person now that's a stupid thing to say
because you're going to crush somebody
emotionally you might put them at risk
um and when I say risk I'm talking about
STI risk I'm talking about all kinds of
risks by the way this is different
this is putting the very bed you lay in
in significant risk
and this is one of the few moments when
I would throw my hands up and step way
way way way back
that's that's why I wrote you
because I I know it it's you know it's
it's not even about trusting so much
because I've never known a man not to
cheat
um it started with my father I don't
four or five times I don't and I'm not a
great guy
I'm not I'm not perfect just just know
they're out there and statistically
speaking there's more of them than those
that do
broken I guess
well
we marry our unfinished business right
right
so my guess is
you're gonna you're gonna make sure that
you are able to to fix that
and you can't fix that
because most of the time Affairs have
nothing to do with the partner sometimes
they do but they have to do with
somebody going out and feeling alive
again
or somebody trying to cover up shame
right well it's the same thing because
if I know that he has financial
difficulties you know the anonymity in
that world makes him feel like a man
again escort doesn't care it makes him
feel like a man again and there's no
work that has to be done that's right
it's cheap cheap Dime Store this is lazy
masculinity that's right that's right
it's bull crap it's fake but all that to
say is
he has chosen by his behavior to put
your actual physical health in
significant Danger
period
things you can't you can't you can't
that's right get an antibiotic form so
if I'm you like and I let's just pretend
you're my sister okay or you're one of
my close friends who's a girl
a woman I would say
um Step number one is I'd go get tested
that'd be step number one and that's for
me and my health
step number two is I'd probably go sit
down with a counselor because you've
been through this before
and this is going to have some
significant weight to it
and the way you couched your previous
marriage that you weren't perfect and
you did some things the just the way you
said that tells me that you were
probably in an abusive relationship and
you have mined the depths of yourself to
figure out what you did to cause some of
that fair
true well I also responded in a tie I
didn't yeah you made dumb choices on the
back end that's fine yeah that's fine
um I mean it's not fine you know what I
mean right it happens but
um
and by the way this guy in his previous
marriage
I don't care how toxic it gets he made a
choice right to endanger everybody so he
wasn't forced into this he didn't his
bad marriage didn't cause this
right and he he continues to deflect and
blame her for nope nope she may have
been the worst person in the world in
the world in the world great he gets to
wake up every day and decide am I going
to be a person of integrity and
character even if that means I'm going
to be a person of character and
integrity as I end my marriage because
it's unsafe
fine yes but I didn't do that too so I'm
also guilty of not doing that that
doesn't mean that doesn't that's you've
chosen the shame route you put that in
your backpack and you're choosing to
carry it around as an I am statement
instead of that's something I did and
that will never happen again
right Fair that's fair stop carrying
that around
you did that it happened and there's a
period and then you get to do something
different this time
and this is why I'm just part of my
question to you is just I just give up
and get a dog because I cannot seem to
no be attracted to somebody that doesn't
do this
I think I think it's time probably for
the first time ever
that you go see a true trauma therapist
and say I need this I need to heal my
body from the inside out
in that journey I have been through some
trauma therapy but it was for the prior
relationship that apparently I still
have work to do I think you got it yeah
there's a difference between trauma
therapy that allows you to
um breathe post significant trauma
but in this situation you're going back
and you have a little girl in there
that's still asking daddy why he kept
running around
and why he didn't show up and that's the
stuff you got to deal with
and my guess is my guess is don't answer
this question but my guess is
uh Mary's Life as a little girl as a
young teenager was really tough
real real tough
so that's what we got to go sit down
because your body's going to continue to
antenna and direct you towards these
toxic relationships until you can
completely unhook from this need to go
solve
and instead connect to Anchor into
the truth that is I'm Mary and I'm worth
being loved
and I'm worth not being cheated on Not
all men are cheaters
I'm worth
um
I don't know any number of things
I'm worth all of it
I'm especially worth more than this
I'm gonna end this the same way I always
do I'm not going to tell you to end your
relationship that's on you I don't want
you saying this podcaster said I had to
do that but I wanted to tell you that as
you've laid it out you're not safe
physically or emotionally and it's time
to take some action to First protect
yourself second heal yourself and then
begin to ask hard questions about this
relationship and relationships moving
forward
thank you so much for the call Mary
we'll be with you holler anytime I can
help we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right let's roll out to Dave in
Philadelphia he was born and raised
what's up Dave
what's up Dr John how are you I'm good
brother how are you
I'm good man I appreciate you uh you
taking the time
um
so I wanted to reach out the the way
that I found you
um I was listening to I think I was
searching for being guilty that I'm
doing better than my parents and sisters
and stuff like that
um I hold
I think a lot of uh of guilt and and I
have you know heavy imposter syndrome
um and then I'm sure you've heard the
term like ego Maniac with an inferiority
complex so
um I'm 38 and yeah what did you survive
I got clean and sober
um when I was 26 I was a really bad
heroin addict cocaine uh not a boy dude
alcohol yeah I was a train wreck bro and
um
so
I think like I've I've it's funny I was
like thinking about this call and I'm
like you might have to do like a Trilogy
for me because there's so many letters
but of course
um there's like now I have this I've
rebuilt everything I I have a great wife
I have three little kids eight six and
three
um I've worked in the the drug and
alcohol treatment realm for a long time
and recently started my own recruiting
firmware like I staffed treatment
centers all across the country
um and can we stop right there
yeah just for a second
okay
dude
you are in rare air my brother
like one percent of the one percent
yeah I I hold on hold on hold on call
them because I want to recognize that I
know so before you even ask your
question you I gotta say this you know
how
um you have that buddy from high school
and you haven't seen him in forever and
you run into them in the like a random
place and they're either
they've put on 50 pounds or they're
super shredded
yeah and the way you look at them is
like this alarm Bell like they see it
and they haven't noticed that over the
last 20 years they've kind of put on
half a pound and half a pound half a
pound and then you see somebody or they
haven't like lost half a pound half a
pound half a pound
and they don't even recognize just how
incredible they are or on what kind of
slippery slope they're they're on and so
I need you to hear man
12 years up
on what I think are some of the hardest
drugs to get off of
yeah heroin because of the of the
biomechanics of it and alcohol because
it's freaking everywhere right yeah
you've done some hard hard work
yeah so hear me say man this is me and
you meeting in a grocery store and we
haven't seen you in 20 years and I just
can't get over how good you look man I'm
proud of you it's amazing
I appreciate that yeah I I need to hear
that I think it's funny like I um I'm a
big self-care seeker and so like still
do regular therapy
um you know do a lot of different
meditation stuff take courses Here There
and Everywhere
um on a big Health kick lost like 30
pounds since uh since Christmas like all
kinds of stuff but I was like talking to
my therapist
um I just did EMDR to try and like
address trauma but like all of this
circles around my fear of of money and
and losing everything and it's so black
and white uh hold on hold on I don't
think that's it
I may be wrong I may be wrong I hope not
that's what I'm calling I may be wrong
but
I'm wondering if you are doing these
things because there is a belief within
you that you will feel a certain way
when you're finally safe
yes 100 that feeling doesn't exist
that that's it because it's like I have
this feeling of like when I have this
much money it's not in the bank I'll be
okay yeah I'll tell you this when you
don't owe anybody any money
and I'll go one step further when you
have an emergency fund when you've got
money is set aside where you're your own
bank right you got six months of
expenses you get fired
there is a physiological shift that
happens inside your body it does
downshift but
that man you based on what drugs you
were into I guarantee your childhood was
chaos wasn't it
yeah
yeah interesting part through tremendous
amounts of therapy was the chaos was
almost created by me due to boredom like
my parents are still married they have a
sick marriage my dad doesn't drink my
mom I've seen maybe drink eight glasses
of wine in her whole life
listen addiction
addiction is about relationship it's not
about substance yeah no so it's it's I
think I was always seeking like the
approval of I was the the skateboard kid
and like to you know you're a music guy
like the punk rock and stuff and I
wasn't the uh you know soccer playing
student council president I think that's
where a lot of it stands and I think now
you know like I'm also uh you know I
found Ramsay through you but like my
emergency fund is almost way too much I
have like well over a Year's worth of
expenses
um I'm paying down the mortgage all my
kids have healthy college funds and like
I said my wife the other day like I got
to put money in Kai's college fund and
my wife's like dude she's three and like
I'm not talking like a hundred bucks I'm
talking like I need to put like five
grand in and it's so manic that it's
driving my wife nuts and I'm starting to
like feel like I don't even want to take
the kids to dinner and and if you looked
at me on paper I mean liquid assets are
there the finances saving like we don't
live anywhere outside of our means but
it's like checking the bank account
you're trying to prove to your kids
that dad's all right
yeah you're trying to prove to my wife
that look look look look look look look
look look look look look at me look at
me look at me I'm doing it
yeah and they don't want that they just
want Dave man
yeah they just want Dave
yeah have you have you seen uh it kind
of Spun up and went by I was on somebody
else's shows on my friend the minimalist
show have you seen that that
conversation that I was first time I
ever talked about that publicly about my
wife which she said to me I know
oh my God was that when you were like
dude we got I got this other thing and
I'm going to speak at the other event
you're yelling in the basement and she
was like Hey we've got to have enough
yeah we've got enough and but that's why
I wrote you the message
the conversation I didn't have a
psychology for enough
right because I was just running and
running and running money was a source
of huge fear in my home growing up
as was
um
personal challenges I had growing up and
on top of all that uh here's the deal
man you you did heroin I made Straight
A's we both had the same trauma like my
I just they just gave me money and gave
me jobs for mine and they got on to you
for years both of us were running
yep my parents are still married too
that doesn't always matter
okay sure so the challenge here is is
not seeking a Feeling
one of the greatest gifts I've had is to
sit next to Dave and because Dave Ramsey
was a broke
crashed
East Tennessee kid from The Hills yeah
he calls him sees a self-proclaimed
hillbilly and there's moments that he
still experiences to this day
um where he says there's times when he
gets the bill you know there's 1100
employees here a thousand employees here
for coffee just for the to for the whole
campus that was more than he he made an
entire year and he said there's still
moments when he like his breath leaves
his body because that East Tennessee kid
I have the exact same thing
the exact same thing so here's the
important thing he's taught me and I'll
pass it along to you I cannot trust my
feelings I can't I'm trying to raise
kids that will learn to trust theirs
but my feelings are entirely
untrustworthy for several reasons
and I'm fine with that
what I then have to do
is kind of like you know the basketball
player Chris Paul he's not seven feet
tall so he has to come up for Steph
Curry he's he's six two six three so
he's got to learn to shoot from really
far away in in really chaotic situations
right you and I have to figure out
another way through this thing because
our bodies have been through the ringer
and our feeling system is just going to
be a lot
it's always going to be telling us
there's there's something around the
corner some around the corner somewhere
around the corner and so that's it
there's two things we gotta do number
one we have to be very crystal clear
about what finish lines look like and we
have to hold to those ratios
what does that mean yeah I will put six
months in an emergency fund and that
will be all I will commit to that
despite how I feel
I will put this much as a percentage
into my retirement and that is it
that's it I moved the goal post on
myself all the time and I think it's
like yes because I I hit those goals and
then I'm like oh cool I made this much
lesser well if I don't make a million
this year I'm a loser I miss I'm that
and it's like that makes sense not
moving the goal post because that's all
I ever do and by the way it's okay for
it to be both hand you could have made a
million bucks last year and make 750
Grand this year and be disappointed
that's okay
yeah that's all right to feel that way
it's all right to look at your business
that went down a huge percentage right
and to look at it and go man what do we
need to look at because next year if it
goes down to 500 000 or my business my
take home has been cut in half
and it's also at the exact same time
really cool to be grateful that you're
making half a million dollars or three
quarters of a million dollars it's both
and yeah right it's both ends yeah
that's that's what I tell like my
therapist like it almost I think I also
feel guilt for feeling the anxiety
because like I look at my
brother-in-law's and and my sisters only
people that like work very hard and like
I think you know on paper I'm relatively
much more stable in the one that they
can go to and it's like but it's not
curbing the anxiety and I think then I
get like the guilt of like you have all
this like this cushion and all these
great things and your kids go to this
great school and your wife could stay
home and like yourself none of that
matters none of that matters
yeah there you go the longer you're
running
the more you just drag your family it's
like it's like they're on a tube behind
a boat and the tube fell over but
they're all still hanging on and you're
just dragging them across the lake and
you're like look how fast we are and
look how big this boat is and they're
like we just want you to stop right
but listen listen here's the thing um
there's there's a part two to that story
I told about my about my wife telling me
hey we have enough
yeah she was struggling too because she
grew up with not a lot also
yeah and so when we both sat down and we
defined what enough is going to be for
the both of us
it actually included taking more
speaking gigs
but it also included me doing other
things in my off time
it also included me being very
intentional about going to see my own
counselor
very intentional about how I take care
of myself what I say no to outside of
these business opportunities
right so it's not like it all goes away
it's me and my wife get together and
co-create something and I gave you one
of them one of them is sit down with
your wife and create
the psychology of enough okay
um the second thing is uh and here's it
it's just it's just ratios
if you're worth a hundred million
dollars right and you buy a hundred
thousand dollar car you have bought a
car that if you you know it's like race
ratio wise sure it's like you bought a
one thousand dollar car for somebody who
makes them like right you see I'm saying
so
lean on the ratios
give like crazy be generous and here's
the second thing
I have to have a group of men in my life
that I Outsource a lot of these
questions to
okay
I am untrustworthy when I get fired up
to myself now I'm not gonna lie to
people at work that's not what I mean by
trustworthy I mean that I feel things
heavily
yeah this person's really pissed at me
this person's about to fire me this
person's not doesn't doesn't want me on
their team whatever
and I've got a few men in my life and
women in my life that I lean into and I
trust and say hey this just happened am
I crazy and they go yes you're being
crazy stop don't respond yep and I'll go
I have to respond because of all I'm not
gonna do it
see what I'm saying that's the hard work
and then here's the honest truth after a
decade of this my feelings are actually
becoming better signals I'm able to read
them better now but it just takes a
while
yeah
yeah you you have you've got to stop
chasing that feeling and just be
committed for a season while your body
relearns
uh I'll I'll
trying to find the right balance between
talking about some of this because I'm
not ready to talk about it all but I've
been through some pretty significant
trauma Counseling in a few maybe a month
ago I went to my counselor and I said
hey look
um
she said how are you feeling and I said
if I gave if I gave a name to it it
would be exhausted or depressed one of
those two feelings and she smiled really
big and she said your body is learning
for the first time
what normal feels like you're just gonna
have to learn what that feels like
that's cool because they're the two that
I feel so that means I'm on the right
track yeah because you've been running
forever and ever and ever and for you
not running feels like impending doom
it does it feels like somebody's gonna
call me the world's gonna fall apart I'm
going to lose a bit and I did this as
the EMDR therapist and she's like you're
frustrated because you try so hard to
understand so much that like you you
cognizantly know what's better but like
it's never going to be enough and like
you're never going to be broke in the
tent asking people like you're not gonna
be able to not provide for your kids
because you have this balance of like
really hard work but also like you're a
little bit overly neurotic with it where
like on paper you couldn't be more safe
like if you sat down with a financial
yeah yeah
that safety is not external and you're
trying to get safe externally and you
can't it's internal yeah I'll tell you
this my account I may have to say this
on the show my counselor told me we can
only you're only going to talk
once every two or three sessions now and
here's her words you've built an
intellectual Fortress around yourself
that is very hard to penetrate and then
she said she said congratulations
and it was not in a positive way you
know what I mean it's like golf clap and
so yeah you have to practice
what does that mean sit with your kids
and play freaking Candy Land until your
brain spins sideways
yeah take one of your young kids and
just go for a walk and point out every
leaf and every Acorn and if you find a
little
um I don't know a little piece of fruit
on the ground throw it at your kid and
let him throw it back at you
or if y'all go swimming do a giant
Cannonball first
go out on the boat and go really really
really slow or get some kayaks and go
even slower
you just need a couple of years of
teaching your body and I did I am
intentional a couple of years takes a
while to teach your body
just stop running now when you get in
the business bro run
fight and Claw and scratch I'm not
saying don't be ambitious and I'm not
saying when you get in the business
World get after it I'm just saying those
metrics won't heal you
what will heal you is connection
connectivity being with your family and
you just got to practice learning to sit
in that
what's uncomfortable right now but will
soon
better than any any heroine is gonna
give your body for that piece
I I can't tell you Dave how proud of you
I am so proud so proud stay on the line
here I'm going to send you a copy of my
book on your past change your future
it's my gift to you actually I'm gonna
send you two one for you and one for
your wife I want you to read it together
and I want you all to work through those
exercises together and um man it's gonna
give you a road map towards building
this non-anxious life we'll be right
back
all right we're back let's go out to
Charleston South Carolina and talk to
the one and only and what's up Ann hi Dr
John thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up okay
so my husband's parents divorced 50
years ago and recently
um we were told that they want to
remarry oh man do they marry other
people after the divorce so yeah a
little bit of background they divorced
when my husband was a newborn his dad
immediately remarried and his mom
remarried thereafter
um and he was raised by his mom and
stepdad he was very close to a stepdad
and
um his dad was in the picture but he
didn't live with him so he doesn't have
a real close relationship with his
father
um and for the time that we've been
married 25 plus years his mom and dad
have had very little contact with each
other to the point that
um like like special occasions baptism
things like that his dad wouldn't even
come to if his mom was going to be there
so
um about a year ago both his step
parents passed away
in a short amount of time from one
another
and
um
his
so now he's got two he's got a mom and a
dad that are newly widowed and
um this past Christmas they were both at
our house his mom and his dad and they
were very cordial with one another we're
talking and they both like to travel
um they're both obviously getting over
the death of a spouse and they had
stayed married to the same spouse for
almost 50 years or not quite 50 years
probably 45 years or so and
um they both got to talking of how they
wanted to travel so about two months ago
they decided to go on a little getaway
together and they told us just as
friends
yeah right just like teenagers right I
guess well and we believe them I guess I
don't know it was kind of I mean even
traveling
to go like you know what maybe it'll be
good for him so
that was about eight weeks ago and then
just recently his mom told him that they
are thinking of remarrying ah baby I
love it how old are they how old are
they they're in their 70s they're in
their 70s hey y'all stay away stay out
of it
okay like like my husband's having a
hard time with it he's gonna have a hard
time with it there's no way around that
um
and there may be some complexity here
like Estate Planning and prenups and all
that kind of stuff I won't get into that
because he may have kids and she may
have other kids like that's all messy
and whatever well my husband is an old
child so he doesn't even have anyone to
like
yeah making a common like sibling to
talk about it with so I here's here's
here's how I would take this and both of
my parents are in their 70s okay so I'm
just speaking how I would internalize
this a that's super weird
super weird be
maybe not the healthiest thing and
also be
when your parents are in their 70s and
they're like we're just getting burgers
and what are you gonna do right right
like what are you gonna do and so you
can
try to get in the middle of this or
y'all can or he can like have a talk
it's too soon you all need to y'all are
still grieving whatever or you can just
say you know what y'all are teenagers
again just go party till the wheels fall
off like what else what's the other
option right right right and I think
he's is afraid of it not working out a
second time because obviously yeah they
didn't ask him
yeah exactly he didn't get a vote and so
it probably won't work out probably or
kind of how we feel it might be
incredible and so so weird so weird
right it is incredibly it's so weird
yeah and even our kids are like what
like yeah so weird all you have to do is
this you have to say ew a lot right
don't say you but here's here's the
reality you and your husband need
especially your husband he had a very
clear picture of what the next 10 or 15
years are going to look like right and
that may be very different now that's
his picture to deal with not theirs
right so I got I had this um this woman
who worked with me she's incredible I
won't use her name here because she I
haven't asked her if that's okay
um she lost her husband and
I met her new husband that they had been
remarried that she'd gotten remarried um
after her husband had passed away
I was awesome
awesome and in a million years I would
not have picked this guy with her and so
I was asking about it I was like dude
this guy's amazing and but so different
than I would have imagined and right I
was talking through like you know how do
you get remarried and how do you rebuild
a life and here's what she said to me
and it it was so profound she said oh
John we're not building a life
she said I did that
I built a life and I built a home I
raised kids I've done that that part of
my life is over I now have married
somebody who's my best friend who's my
ride or die and we're going to get old
and we're gonna get wrinkled up together
and we're gonna go to the lake every
weekend
and it was such a powerful transition
for me right like oh you you and I have
very different goals relationally I'm
trying to keep my marriage together like
duct tape and bailing wire and trying to
figure out how to raise a teenager
y'all are just going to the lake baby
right it's a it was a totally different
mindset and so I'm not going to impose
it does it doesn't it doesn't lessen the
sacredness of marriage and all that it's
just different stages right yeah and so
they say hey we're gonna we're going for
it
I I mean what
I mean why not that's what I told my
husband I said it's their life they're
not telling us how to live our life so
we really can't tell them how to live
their life so if that's what they want
and if it doesn't work out that's on
them it's not on us yeah and you could
tell them hey if this thing it works out
all the way to the right or Die end we
will be so happy and if it doesn't work
out I'll be here for you you both can
call me that's cool yeah
oh it is make no mistake no it went from
a little getaway just as friends and now
we're thinking about getting married and
he's like oh like it's it's hardly been
a year since your spouse has passed away
and now you're and and her thing is she
says she doesn't like being unwed and
that he will take very good care of her
okay
so here's the deal okay
like the the notebook and the Titanic
are over now right right I mean that
season's passed yeah and Safety and
Security and love and commonality and
ooh like all that's awesome
right it's just different it's totally
different stages and so how old are you
guys
we're in our 50s okay you you know it's
you're it's starting to accelerate
but you are because you've become aware
probably over the last five to ten years
how insanely precious minutes and hours
are
sure right if you just met it doesn't
move proportionally it's like compound
interest that pressure and that feeling
you feel like my wife told me a few
months ago oh my gosh we only have five
Spring Breaks left with our son
oh then he's gone and I was like what
you know I mean like five spring breaks
and I missed the last two traveling for
work that's over that I never I got five
left you're you're you're you're further
down the road than I am you start to see
how precious this time is when you get
to be 70 that s that that that that
accelerates in such a powerful way and
so I would your husband's gonna have to
grieve because he had a picture and that
picture is gonna be different it that
might be different because his parents
are back together it might be different
that he's got to deal with his dad that
he felt bailed on him and that may be
part of the issue yeah any number of
things but I think
the posture is y'all are crazy but good
for y'all yeah I mean what I mean what
do you do do you think this is too
soon but
it's your life
I want you to have as much fun as
possible in your remaining time together
I don't know right I don't know why you
would hope for anything other than that
right right right and that's what I told
him I said you know they're older they
they have all these years down the road
like a younger couple would be you know
so waiting a year or two to get married
is not really it may not be in the
courts for them so maybe that's why they
want to hurry up well and here's the
deal
none of us get a vote right unless my
dad sat me down or my mom called and sat
me down and said I need you to be very
specific with me am I making the worst
mistake of my life and even then I would
probably say I can't tell you that if
you want to be with somebody and this is
the dude for the for the last 10 or 15
years of your life yeah and
statistically they're already playing on
house money right now right right and so
who knows what tomorrow brings once you
are in your mid 70s and on you're
playing on house money and so let's have
as much fun and joy and love as possible
yeah right right good advice thank you
I will pass it on to him okay good luck
with that good luck with that I know I
know it's not gonna be easy
um and I'll just say this I'm smiling
this whole call it's it's
I I just it brings me joy it just does
there's so much heartache and so much
um
I I can't wrap my head around losing
somebody that you were with for 50 years
50 years uh I can't wrap my head around
that and so the idea that two people
found each other albeit pretty quickly
found each other and we're like are you
in I'm in let's just see how much gas is
left in this in this old truck I that
just brings me joy that makes me smile
and again there's going to be estate
things to figure out there's going to be
Insurance things to figure out there's
gonna be all that stuff that's that's
all a pain in the butt and you can't
skip those steps you gotta deal with
those things
but just at its core
I mean what else are you gonna do you're
gonna shut down your 75 year old mom and
be like no
you you call me before you date again no
man you're gonna you're gonna say
knock your lights out guys you all have
a good time and we'll be there at the
wedding and uh maybe you and your dad
have to have a hard conversation that's
fine or maybe just not maybe just not
thanks for calling and you're awesome
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back um as we wrap up
the show We're not gonna do a song today
um
I've come to believe that my wife is a
children's literature expert if you will
and um uh
children's literacy is is her expertise
and I've come to believe that children's
literature is
um through her example into her teaching
children's literature holds some of the
most profound truths expressed in this
most simple ways
um it was the it was Churchill the great
Churchill I think who said
um if you need me to come speak tomorrow
for 12 hours
um I can do it if you need me to speak
for 30 minutes I need six months
because distilling truth and Distilling
honesty and Distilling a great
um
profound truths in a teeny tiny
directional way is very hard and this
book called um the rabbit listened by
Corey dorfeld
um it's just a masterpiece so we're
gonna have story time I'm gonna read it
if you want to turn over to roll over to
YouTube if you're listening to this and
check it out or we'll put this the book
in the show notes
um it's one of those books I think every
kid should have on their Shelf
Corey dorfeld just a masterpiece here's
the book
one day Taylor decided to build
something something new something
special
something amazing and Taylor was so
proud
but then out of nowhere a whole bunch of
black birds just flying and knock these
things down
things Came Crashing Down
and he's just looking over a pile of
blocks that have all been knocked down
the chicken was the first to notice
clock what a shame I'm so sorry sorry
this happened let's talk talk about it
cluck cluck but Taylor didn't feel like
talking so the chicken left
next came the bear
how horrible I bet you feel so angry
let's shout about it
but Taylor didn't feel like shouting so
the bear left
the elephant knew just what to do
I can fix this we just need to remember
exactly the way things were
but Taylor didn't feel like remembering
so the elephant left
one by one they came the hyena let's
laugh about it the ostrich gulp let's
hide and pretend nothing happened the
kangaroo what a mess let's throw this
all away and the snake shh let's go
knock down someone else's
but Taylor didn't feel like doing
anything with anybody So eventually they
all left until Taylor was alone
in the quiet Taylor didn't even notice
the rabbit but it moved closer and
closer until Taylor could feel its warm
body
I'll be dude I'm gonna get all choked up
reading this book God almighty
together they sat in silence until
Taylor said please just stay with me and
the rabbit listened
the rabbit listened as Taylor talked and
the rabbit listened as Taylor shouted
the rabbit listened as Taylor remembered
and laughed
and the rabbit listened to Taylor's
plans to hide to throw everything away
to ruin things for someone else
through it all the rabbit never left
and when the time was right the rabbit
listened to Taylor's plan to build again
I can't wait Taylor said
it's gonna be amazing
the greatest gift people have ever given
me during times of dark tragedy and Mild
personal life
it's just showing up and saying nothing
just being there
thank you for being here with us
and I'm glad I get to be here with you
we'll see you soon stay in school don't
do drugs
foreign